voi saprete ultimi sono i giudei sono
tornati su job simulator allo ragazzi
simul ha fatto solo soltanto un
tentativo facciamone un altro fatto bene
fargli mica quanto è bella sensazione
fare così ragazzi perfetta o perfetto se
vi dico la verità non mi ricordo una
mazza di sta roba quindi mi ricordo che
avevo iniziato il kun il gourmet chef e
oggi facciamo i potuti chef ragazzi miei
oggi chef pavin insegna a cucinare
globali di qualità di date gli ordini vi
date qualcosa se qui per ordinario
perché atteggiare testa via cavo i cani
ti sto parlando
questa come fare a botte testa di
minchia vigor è l'icona non viene o ecco
lo faccio questo dai la zuppa devo
iniziare a mettere dell'acqua dentro la
bacinella va bene dove la trovo la
bacinella non nel frigo aiuto bot
perfetto laporte ce l'abbiamo con il
bicchiere vuoi che ne ha sei scemo con
la casa del momento e l'acqua nella
tazza poi dentro la pentola che problemi
al cervello c'hai non posso mettere la
pentola dentro l'aveva affanculo affari
a meta faccia bene la zuppa madonna
parola che c'è proprio può accompagnare
sono ragazzi sono la zuppa più causa di
tutti i tempi come lo dico qualche merda
cioè le cene sapone renderlo sicuro dei
pinguini frate secondo te con un
bicchiere d'acqua riusciamo a fare una
zuppa nato lo chiede
datevi delle carote vi prego caro eccole
qua perfetto questo non te la infili nel
culo non ci arrivo perché c'è il divano
porca [ __ ] cazzo di divano ok una cosa
vuoi di altro pomodoro ha posto una
carota e un po zuppa di merda è questo
proprio dai andiamo ragazzi io vi dico
solo una roma l'ultima volta contatto
fuoco una pentola in casa mi è rimasto
il segno sulla sola cucina perché ho
bruciato tutto bene che non è proprio il
massimo già fatto
bisogna fare un accenno ad esso non aver
non sa che non avevamo capito
giustamente la fisica come funziona così
cosa mi andavo faccio creare in fisica
non capivo bene
ecco qua la zuppa sapone una carota è un
pomodoro allora tu al baker
vediamo se devo fare un semplice la
zuppa è uscita così non lo so pensava il
sangue cioè fratello però allora
partiamo col pane di questa cosa so fare
solo questa però non lo so fare neanche
questo zercar a ok usa hanno capito
secondo me non si fa così siamo all uovo
nuovo giusto okc di gigi d'alessio lo
centro c'è un'altra facciamo un arancio
veramente a kabul limone michiel
semplici della vita ragazzi adesso un
pomodoro così dopo il suo smette anche
il cactus no che peccato ma proprio
tocco di classe coscia di pollo è
perfetto perfetto mi chiama 5 stelle
michelin
vabbè gliele che abbiamo fatto ragazzi
manca solo libetta che ha messo sempre
cari a prova messa dopo ok è la cosa più
buona che abbiamo mai riguardo mangerei
o se non fosse che non mi sta nello
stomaco dov'è messo anche da la mia
creatura è anche servito con un po
d'uovo che non si sa da dove viene
quindi direi che meglio di così non è
fp è dimenticato latte frate
ecco che serve ancora fare la vi sto
divertendo come un bambino ve lo dico e
bellissimo escluso le visite masterchef
anzi adesso ridarci la nostra domanda
perché siano devolute krikic cercato
sopra entro dunque re ma sai con chi
stai con un brutto demente ago griglia
ha capito è a posto
alfio scusa se fissiamo negli occhi
mentre stava cuocendo sta merda o ti
devo raccontare una parola d'italiano
voi francesi del calcio prevede vspp che
voi avete la motion eye ex cosa fate
fate fate fate fatica ti ci devi stare
zitto
devi stare zitto è successa una cosa ne
sa niente a porta a mangi che tanto sei
francesi luca il vinello vuole lui mica
se proprio aspirante testa di cazzo non
lo trovo il vino no non si tiene frigo
vino si tiene nel cioccio amica dove al
bando punto serve come fanno le sue
tenute di vino ho trovato ho trovato un
libro lowell libro non lo è il libro è
che tieni questo questo vino e vino vino
rose rose è protetto dove lo trovo il
think esso
escluse le petit stronze allora eccolo
quale vintage capre di gissi le un ps
giusta nassa gen
per capirsi se stagione la gioconda come
mancia la gioconda grazie exception aver
inchiodato la marcia grazie mixa faccio
ma cosa è mamma mia questa sono soldi
sono miei fratelli sono di gelo che sono
miei
a casa mia si usa che la mancia la dai a
chi fa le cose il marmo la cliente sei
scemo affanno castoro degli stati il tdm
piglia quello che voleva
c'è in una parola lega ce l'ha la mancia
il brema me lasciamo perdere non me ne
frega un cazzo o ragazzino al male
speciali teca ieri la pizza finalmente
possiamo far vedere che gli italiani ce
l'hanno più grosso però in alto il nome
della patria cucinando una pizza con i
contro maroni alla voce blender io non
ho mai fatto una pizza in vita mia e
ragazzi però questo potrebbe essere un
buon modo per iniziare a milioni da via
dal banco che non sono stato io le
tornato e ci siamo fermi un attimo che
perfetto gli schemi come ora questa cosa
qua poi riusciamo ad arrivare alla pizza
fratello per questa roba qua non c'entra
un cazzo se tu vuoi dirmi che s'è detto
questo nel microonde diventa una prima
tu sai come si cucina fratello povero
sono stare ma facciamolo che dici te
spiegami come questa merda può diventare
un hub e spiegando come diventa una
pizza carica ma che tappo di bottiglia
francesino trova da fame la diventa una
pizza un formaggio e formaggio sia ok
trasformato gli stranieri che mettetele
a marana sulla pizza
in realtà penso faccia più cagare di
questa nec ragazzi questa è la pizza are
made by pani j
non dite a nessuno è che questo è un
metodo si è chiuso
fabio ma che ansia ragazzi siete tutti
curiosi come vedi vedere il risultato di
st brodaglia perfetto ma qualcosa ma
cos'è pizza con salame e fiori info
smangiucchiata ma 20 regalo anche questa
bistecca omaggio buona con atleti tra
invece della melma due guide alla meta
ok se come revocò sta roba
secondo me i ragazzi dopo sta roba
dipendono masterchef vuoi che metta
questo anello nel semplice perché vuoi
fare una sorpresa alla tua ragazza
secondo me con questa roba qua la [ __ ]
arriva che un piacere proviamo erano
state funziona
nel dubbio posso termini diamante potevi
pensare di portarla non so in crociera
fare un bel viaggio in montagna sulla
neve lo ammettiamo un anello in un cazzo
di semplici complimenti bravo
grazie gesù poi guarda se non c'è
leonardo in questo matrimonio che non lo
so quando questo è per te
nono gigi d'alessio non lo è gigi
d'alessio non lo metto lo hanno detto al
mito 6 jack sammy costringere no no va
bene lo zio devi stare zitto va bene
l'anello va bene che metto le cose per
far ringrazia ma gigi d'alessio no dai
porca eva lercia
io ho dato fuoco
ho dato fuoco uncini gigi d'alessio per
quale motivo devo distruggere la frutta
vecchia così sennò non passate
l'ispezione un alimento nelle mutande
cosa faccio
para il culo mi metto a posto
sono a posto cucinato ho fatto vedere
che gli italiani cucinano meglio cosa
che era ovvio ragazzini spero che questo
film sia piaciuto spero che vede
imparato a cucinare oggi molto più di
ieri visto che vi ha insegnato a fare le
cose
quindi ragazzi con quello che è più
massa quante zoom agosto provino e siamo
100 ragazzi cose mi piace al momento mi
piace anche alla pagina di facebook e
come migliore tiziana è stato così
rischiate non ci vediamo al prossimo
vito bella ragazzi